[Music]
welcome all right and we are live
welcome to the iron Lords podcast
episode number 78 and it's another
glorious Sunday and we are back at the
roundtable on the Lord's Day no time
today
11:00 a.m. of extremely excited about
our special guests so we're gonna get
right into it I want to introduce a Lord
who I had the absolute pleasure of
meeting in the flesh at PAX East 2018
this law is not only one of the most
passionate game developers in the
industry but also combines his
incredible skill set with the heart of
an artist while still creating total
immersion in the game worlds he creates
introducing the senior world builder at
undead labs the 3d environment artists
in Lord of gamed level design fellow
state of the k-fed fellow destiny fame
making his debut into the realm of the
lord's mommy Lord Lewis Yepez how're you
doing sir
get around man I told you he's gonna
bring out the red carpet with you I need
to record that I just complain that when
I meet people pleasure to have you in
the realm long overdue like I said
you're a lord in your room so it's only
right we shall get a proper respect here
at the round table are you ready to have
some fun in the realm of the Arts
yeah of course and of course we have the
Four Horsemen of gaming those usual
suspects at the round table
my co-host with the commotion my brother
from another mother
the difficult game Conqueror and the
half of the young wolf mommy
Lord addict how you doing sir first
doing pretty good are first off I'd like
to point out that you started a minute
early so now I'm more tired than I
should have
[Applause]
[Music]
the day before yesterday I tried that I
tried that and I had to get that counted
running on like 45 minutes to sleep it's
not always the best thing had me hooked
all week I was like you know what I'm
gonna try the first episode of the iron
fist and then ended up bench watching
[Laughter]
that's right
wait about 30 minutes to Spiderman and
that's it I've been playing that's I
have probably put more time in destiny
than some of these people in play gaming
all year in like and of course you know
we have our most technical gaming lord
the solo gamer who lives for the single
player selfish experience and also the
sashed Adamas mister often profile
Illuminati and Lord page one of the iron
bank mommy
Lord sovereign are you doing sir I am
fantastic underway games are coming oh
man you know I'm going to assuming a
soon selfish player single player solve
has been touching nothing with
spider-man you assume correctly what
[Music]
that money let's go ahead and play it
whatever you want no no it did anything
else besides vitamin yeah I mean I did I
play some destiny I play a little bit of
the story um in forsaken um a couple of
matches a gambit I play a little bit
with addict but that was pretty much it
once by the man was in the house that
was a wrap for that and then I switch I
feel like I feel like the people that
wanted a gray day one it's like we're in
a a non yeah yeah we're in a you do this
so you don't play mode right now when I
played with addict he was like I need to
be at that level
I cannot need to be 610 we're trying to
get this country we found that the the
the the what's gonna happen
begins in that level and when we're not
giving it out if you watch cactus I
shout out the cactus thank you so much
sir his video his latest video no
business ladies but go to his catalog
brother and make sure make sure that you
go and you find out how to get to its
dirt place I can go just to buy some
garam like God six is six top-level now
just would you say Lord Lord Louise
would you say you get to 600 without
rape the use of you could never hit yeah
technically you can but it's still a
grind but there's some it's it's a soft
cap that's at 500 and you have to
finagle your way to get up to 600 and
everybody
well my clan is very astute once we find
out something we spread it out like a
virus throughout the Klan and make sure
that everybody who's serious about it is
doing you know the techniques to get to
set level absolutely and of course we
have the Incredible Hulk of this aka the
excess gamer oh the lord of combat so am
i delayed by the way
the Lord of combat sports who was a man
of his convictions demands nothing less
than that premium experience in is the
leader of the fraud alert movement Oh
beloved Lord King are you doing sir
we're doing incredibly good today we
have a very special guest and I cannot
wait to we get into how we know each
other and stuff like that that's curvy
really fun within itself but last night
we had a fight go to the YouTube channel
to get that combat talk the results is
going about that it's being that the
show is earlier today I didn't get a
chance to do the result portion of the
show I will do the results portion of
the show right after this um let's get
it to who's loaded and throw it in the
nice Creek alright first first first and
foremost I gotta give my badge at a week
to Lord addict Lord addict has has been
above and beyond what you would you
expect as a clan meet which would I mean
every charm he's seen my xbox turned on
and it was a party invite and if I
didn't get there fast and if he jumped
in my party like graaah what's up what
are we doing I need to get this done
sinister he has sinister in tow he
didn't let sinister go have surrounded
men who come to with us we're doing this
we dual rates biscuits legit I'm not I'm
not about playing with the berated
Guardians okay listen let's get to that
fraud alert and it's going out to one
person this week who exhibited the
qualities of a super fraud people kneel
before God
oh damn
yeah he's a super fraud I'm not gonna
tell you how to spell it you can figure
it out if you find it um when you are in
a raid and we was in the easy way just
to get the completion so everybody in
the clan can get the Ingram mm-hmm we
were at gauntlet standing on our plate
we wasn't doing the UM the prestige the
run punch uh top strap we wasn't doing
that we wasn't doing prestige strat
alright we were doing the regular strap
you still on your plate you shoot top on
your on and on Cup and top on axis
around their punch your side on your
right back you let the water do its
thing do you call outs
mm-hmm and it was something going on
over there with dog team and we couldn't
figure it out and so sinister stop
yelling out you okay we got a Frodo
he's messing up and it kept happening at
the same dungeon like he kept catching a
brain fart at the same exact moment so
what we did we we try to save him from
his brain fart epilepsy attack that he
was having and we said yo you run and he
got ëletís on us I said I don't want oh
so when it was time to grab the orb and
we said everybody go inside
I'm not running Wow we got someone
refused to run in the Leviathan gauntlet
stay he folded the raid fraud style we
all love we all know he did a whole
bunch of things in there that was
actually super fraud worthy but then
later on in the day like probably like
ten minutes later he jumps in a party
with us and he comes in with his tail
between his legs and he's like the king
I'm sorry because everybody thought I
was gonna go off how I miss that that's
all
wait at the exact time he came in and
said I'm so my pride and I said you know
I feel that mm-hmm it's still at the
same time as him trying to Humble
himself he still couldn't allow meeting
to tell him we knew you were wrong we
all should were you looks like
somebody's stealing and in line and
we're watching them put the stuff but
either a really test will test those
friendships but the gun was designed to
test that stuff absolutely yes it's not
that is that is that the taken King raid
that rate that rate had you like okay
that dudes out of the Klan yes what
happened with him before I forgot in the
thinking king bit like humane Stein
doesn't play anything else but we're you
know our clients kind of casual and that
part where you got to go through the
ships you know likes everybody get
through it I mean it's kind of painful
because it's not a platform game or it's
like I understand that but this guy
could not jump but I love them too it's
a really good friend of mine
you had on PlayStation you can actually
like do the request take control over
somebody's controller yes and do and
play them so we I actually like logged
off send a request and you know played
his character while watching the stream
and jumped him over over all the shifts
left him on the other side walk myself
back in and into the rate jumped the
puzzle again and went over and the only
reason was so that he could get loot
because if you thought he could bypass
that and then just join us one room
later you know what's funny
you just described Lord kognito give me
Virgil control wow I will pass you you
were to like the jump was just different
I mean the hunters though it's like I'm
like I'm not me you were the superior
race of the job so that was the deal
sake it took a toll on my soul it's like
I told I said he folded my evening
that's a gap which you've been playing
man besides destiny than all destiny
this week or any Spidey I'm a fraud I'm
a fraud I mean I purchased my spider-man
I tweeted it out my spider-man is
sitting right there in a wrapper
boom I don't understand you know and I
gotta tell you something
Lord sovereign you don't understand how
real that 600 level got you you have to
be like I don't know why we are in a
clan to where if we if we ain't hidin if
ever a day they'll be like you just
gonna have to give her place there's no
raising like there's no rate for you
somebody's telling you no soup for you
spider-man is in the bushes right now
and so I forget myself
of course we have the gaming [ __ ]
himself this shinobi Lord Cognito
surprise everyone is in the realm of the
ILP not telling you what you would hit
but what you need to hit so yeah I mean
obviously that's like the rest of the
Lords here it's been in destiny too once
you got past I got past the 500 soft cap
grind it's been it's been pretty slow I
actually took the week off for work
that's not savage I was for this was the
500 grind is real it's definitely real
you have to get your powerful gear loop
sources in order to grind I want to
shout out the arm if anyone got the ace
of spades that is an amazing quest so
well so really yes I got it I got it too
and um shout out to I want to shout out
to obviously negative feeling the decay
character but it really adds context to
the story after the campaign and I don't
want to spoil it but whatever I know the
quest steps are very hard for people who
don't like PvP get it done I'm gonna
tell you right now Nolan North does a
fantastic job
as Cain and it gives you extra little
funny insight is almost like a will and
it's hilarious please do that question
transmen what happened yeah you the
crimson you have trouble with the going
to gambit part where they want the five
invasion kills one you you did context
is wrong is not that you have to be the
invader you have to shut down people who
are invading in gambit once you get that
then you get the 25 precision kills of
crucible which is also tough but if you
can get past that there's a final
mission that is amazing all respects
decay they really send them off right
really good
obviously spider-man I was touching that
a little bit still touching all saying
them doctrine Shepherd so that's pretty
much what I've been rocking in real
quick I know our King has done a combat
talk you know I mean but I had a shout
out also there was UFC last night as he
cycle gaming a chat shout out to
tyronn Woodley great boy yeah man for
the young what the young bold dare until
is soft did you see it yeah I remember
the very person the very first time I
saw time word Woodley it was a long time
ago well I was like see that
like The Incredible Hulk like the dude
was huge in his weight class
he's an absolute beast in that division
and arm yeah bigger than him though
he'll his monstrous overturned tail is
cutting so much weight to action
division and you know this was a big
test this was a big test for our time
Ron he looked good striking was good
still got tremendous power drop the boy
second round
and when he showcases besides the
wrestling did you Jitsu beautiful choke
well I think was a DARS I believe he
slept in the dark choke like unbeknownst
to Darrin till he kind of all came to
sleep long in sleep it slipped in the
DARS and then and in the ground and
pound first dropped and he's gonna be
the only thing he's sometimes a little
too passive that you know he's annoying
sometimes passive like yeah but he gets
going like any probe like he's just a
superior fighter shoutout to come on
we'll see what happens gonna be Colby
next and all that good stuff but um yeah
that's pretty much what I've been
planning and watching so now that we got
into all of that
hello palm for probably the hottest song
I'm telling you right now if you haven't
seen it I heard my song I'm telling you
I purchased it on three platforms I got
a streaming service okay I purchased it
on Google I purchased it from the
streaming service and Amazon and I
downloaded it and paid for it from
another site so trust me when I tell you
you'll love it literally it is um post
interview so post fight interview said I
was kind of liars
is that is that beans that way we got
into what the Lord's are playing this
week I want to start off with Lord nice
his video game system history his
drawing is a 3d
vironment artists and level designer of
many very games throughout the industry
and of course would let him to become
the senior world builder and undead labs
soul or Louise I start from the very
beginning though what was some of the
first game systems you had kind of what
got you in a game so my actual first own
system was the Super Nintendo oh that
was my first own that was not the first
system that was playing non-stop I think
it was like IBM computer ok
like early early 90s and stuff like that
it was a my uncle would have one at my
grandparents house and so I remember
when I would visit them I would like
play all these games that he had there
mmm maybe some rhymes on that idea it
was names from game names it was a one
of those really old computers I don't
remember what it was it but it's like
Prince of Persia like hey let's go the
old-school one like you know black and
white yes
graphics and stuff like that I played
that quite a bit and then he owned a
Nintendo system afterwards and I
remember we had a trip in in the in the
United States and I'm for originally
from Mexico nice so he actually asked my
mom to buy him all these games and stuff
like that to bring back and we did and I
would just like non-stop play you know
Mario Mario Brothers there and yo Noi I
remember you annoying I am I thought it
was just a superhero character or around
chasing the other Noi I didn't know it
was a commercial thing yeah that was big
deal back then I was pretty popular
lower Louise out of Annette yeah no I
mean I to me it was just a game and then
I was like oh they're using that game
character for these like pizza things
[Laughter]
you know he had a Tori as well and it
was like Tarzana would play on the Atari
I think it was nice I love that game her
old games Bomberman
so first system I actually owned was the
Super Nintendo and I remember got it as
a it's like you did good in school kind
of good for you yeah but I remember
you've been convincing my mom like blood
this is like so much better than these
other consoles if you're gonna get me
one you know this is look at this it's
just a better value for your money in
putting that kind of stuff up I didn't
get it and I just like got glued to the
TV with like Super Mario World it was
just you know cuz I think it came
bundled with it
I forgive me yeah but that was like the
game that I remember getting before that
and the next one I remember playing a
lot for it was a street fighter because
I got the console but the games were my
responsibility and I was like 10 at the
time or something like that I think so I
would have to go in wash cars and I
would charge people like 50 cents those
days I love it I love I feel terrible
for the people to let me wash their cars
because I think that I left on water
when I but you know these people do they
know money for something like what I
would charge it was not very much to me
seemed like a lot but you know and so he
like saved up enough and Street Fighter
240 no because I would just play
non-stop at the arcades with me to the
store to get milk or whatever is that it
was and I would just like stay way
longer because they had an arcade Mortal
Kombat arcade and a Street Fighter
arcade there and I would just spend
whatever was left over on it so there
was never any change what you would ask
is I just spent it on the yeah I think
exact change later so I would like I
would try to figure out what I did but I
try to figure out how to like trade
things and some of it just to get some
money to go
nice yeah that I played that quite a bit
and from this Nintendo you know just I
think that's what I was already in love
with games but that's what it's like it
just kind of grounded me into like yeah
this is this is what I want to be doing
in my life I don't know what part of it
but I want to be involved in something
related to this and then I got the 64
that it's before I'm I'm a very
single-player focused gamer couldn't
like care about it or you know
competitive games look like other than
fighting games look I got the 64 that
was like the the option for me doesn't
say hey what do you want you want the
Super Mario 64 or do you want Mario Kart
those were the two um Sage's decisions
and are for the instant before was was
the truth yeah well the decision I had
to make was how much do I want to share
the console at the time being a single a
Singlish for like the majority of my
life was I don't have to share anything
he would like you know want to play with
me and stuff like that and he was really
into cars like he bought me into and no
he wasn't gonna get no play I think he
wasn't wanting me to get Mario Kart he
was trying to hint at it but I'm like no
I want this for myself I purchased the
games in the house so you know Kai BOTS
who had to play what was there that's
you play what I get still to this day on
that same regimen because you buy
everything you know play everything but
you buy everything yeah
a game sharing is the best using mario
64 for reasons amazing game though bill
don't regret it because it was a great
game I ended up getting the others later
but the thing was like all my consoles
inside was that my parents would usually
like chip in or something to like help
me get the console but the games were
usually on my own right I hate anything
else like unless it was like a birthday
or something like that like anything
else was on by yourself so you really
had to think very very carefully about
what game are you gonna get as a present
or what game are you actually combined
stuff because you know there's just not
as much of a breadth of games like there
is now and you hadn't really really
choose carefully so played a lot of 64
game like gold and I like that was like
for me one of the great great game and
then something started happening really
because with the 64 I started like just
seeing all these you know 3d gaze of our
six for gold and gosh like just all this
stuff but then those are called the
platformers we're still trying to make
their way through the 64 there was like
they had the big height at Super
Nintendo and it felt like they just kept
coming over so I just could have like I
kind of didn't care much about them
anymore because it was like well the
same thing why I want more like these 3d
puzzles in games and stuff instead of
the platen warmer stuff not to say that
they weren't great games when the last
one during that era that I remember
doing a lot was I think it's called
mischief-makers it was like kind of
anime it was like this anime character
girl that was like got into robots were
put on like masks or so it was like very
very out there okay and but it was fast
paced it was really really fun and that
was one of the last platformers that I
actually enjoyed cuz I wanted more like
banjo kazooie and notch's I'm like if
you're gonna mean a platformer give me
data on the 64 I don't want the Super
Nintendo kind of gotcha mischief-makers
was treasure
I mean treasure like you know there's
gunstar heroes like oh it was those guys
oh yeah
okay yeah so that's you know I kind of
like with that um getting older and so
we moved to Cancun when I was in that
era of gaming
yes
and he was livin it up he was moved to
the town it was like out of necessity
for work for myself at at the time like
we just moved there and so the
environment is so much more different
than living in Mexico City so Gaming
kind of started to you know taking a
little bit of a second seat on my
priority list and I'm like making new
friends trying to like get to know the
city it's the flame that became big so I
called it like I had a big like I think
it said how do you say it Lowell like I
had a big like dip in gaming in my life
and looking back I think was something
like two years so it's not that big but
it feels like it because I didn't really
come back into gaming until like the end
of the ps1 era middle me get one era and
stuff like that that I really got
interested back the way I got interested
back was I went back to Mexico City to
visit a friend of ours that we would
play basketball together as we were
playing and everything and you know
telling him how it's going in Cancun and
he invites me back to his house it's
like all dude let me show you my place
agent don't like a we go and this is
when I found out about pirated beings
right so I never seen like a like a
pirated game or I didn't even know that
was the thing I go to his place and he
has these like just photocopied covers
of yes like forearm high right like do
you have a book like it would all the CD
sleeve like real games PlayStation 1 era
graphics because I have just stopped
playing so you know this is the first
time I'm looking at it and I had lost
interest in in games a little bit during
that time so oh yeah she starts showing
them to me and there's this one game and
that's like that's why they all came
back like he shows me a Soul Reaper
sorry
we were those me this game and for one
looked amazing right I was just like my
jaw dropped I was like whoa this looks
great and then he does the shifting in
the game where he goes becomes yes and
the environment just like moving in
front of you no loading known as
seamless Oh like a CG trailer sequence
it's like real-time in front of you
shift the entire world looks completely
different you see the geometry been and
everything it was I was like I wasn't
sure if I was like hi or what the hell
is this game I need to know more about
it and that's like inside I think that's
when I knew I'm like this is what I
wanted this is where I wanna be I want
to make eyes whatever sensation I just
had looking at that I want to make that
happen so soul in those games that just
started pulling me in but you know the
money for a Playstation so I found uh I
made a friend you been afraid who had a
system
baby monitor system ya know they had one
and so I would lived at their house in
Cancun like I lived in that house I
would go get out of school and I would
go there and I would have lunch and
dinner there and I was playing games I
think their dad probably you know hated
me because I literally lived I did the
school was munching at the house like
they were just everybody was there it
was the house to be at even what it
sounds like look I need Oh sounds bad
like you know beginning of high school
and that everybody would just like hang
out at this house and so I did
everything there except for sleeping and
you know sometimes I would even sleep
there so yeah I just played a Resident
Evil and those and then Silent Hill was
definitely the other one in Silent Hill
was the one that sold me on irony I
wanted to do that
but seeing the storytelling of the
atmosphere he likes it all gather around
and when one person was playing the game
but we were all there was like watching
a movie or something yes let me ask you
a question always cuz you sparing my
present even in Silent Hill all that
stuff like did you guys do it how the
Lord did like we made like a cinematic
experience like you had to Rights had to
be dim we had yeah it was a small room
yes
tiny one-bedroom like a kid and the
system was so you know like 15 teenagers
crammed in there I didn't smell very
good because you just live there light
talk we also had a rule where I believe
we weren't able to play until like after
8 o'clock though that none know kind of
like Sun glare would like you really
wanted the ambience mm-hmm and so we we
did that and we just played through that
I was like I didn't know you could get
that kind of experience from a game and
that was like wow like so yeah yeah you
could really push this thing sorry those
are the games are just like really stuck
with absolutely and that if I I loved
that was the love thing yeah if I recall
I was not really had like the fog effect
and yeah put you in a gigantic in your
buzzer I'm just loving we're having the
same exact experience you having a
Mexico City in the Bronx yes you're
having the same exact experience with
turning off the lights
everybody hold around one guy and
everybody you took me back when you were
saying it that's why I was smiling and I
looked at myself cheesing like a wild
chest it's just this is what games do
this is why it did stupidity when it
comes to separating yourself from cops
you just heard he went from Nintendo the
Sony and it did there was no no fighting
on none of that it's just love and this
experience when you cut yourself off
from all these other systems and stuff
like that you
is that their kinship that we have right
there free said something that resonated
gaming I got goosebumps
thank you so much for sharing that part
of you that is inside of me thank that
just it was just great right he
literally took us right there'll be what
you were right was the exact same thing
the Lords were doing back in the day and
it was just it was an event when these
games came out and we all got around
that TV we all you're lined up you know
what's funny
the latest experience was I had these
same experiences and the prime example I
know you guys going to get dealt with in
super smash brothers ohh i partied up
with people i mean we did the same thing
with tekken we did the same thing with
us it was to say it was that competitive
nature in games like lord louisa and
then cinematic story gears because that
was kind of debuted at that time like
you said the resident rose
the Silent Hill don't first true horror
games that really scared you and it was
like a rule that you couldn't play it
with the lights we have to be immersed
ourselves up in the game in the dog
could team lore Louise these are great
stories like I've noticed here like
talking to you since I've moved to the
u.s. like I'm talking to people that
grew up with those systems around the
same air and stuff if you think there's
there was a lot more like
acknowledgement around games yes and
people knew that gaming was a you know a
an entertainment thing you had like you
knew people that had it like Beckworth I
grew up it wasn't just rare so my entire
life I've been like you know in love
with comics I've been in love with like
movie like nice just all this stuff but
there was never an environment where I
could actually like grow that or have
other people so these few instances
where we did get together with other
people were farm few and in-between like
Silent Hill was one of the very few
where I was able to be improv everything
after that it's really just me being by
myself so it didn't nurture that's not
of like gaming and like that nerd
culture that everybody lives now yeah so
for me right now I'm living in the life
because everybody knows you know what
I'm talking about and I've seen my wife
about
spider-man or about like Iron Man and
all those things even though I'm not as
deep into the knowledge bases a lot of
other people do I get to explain it to
her nothing that slowly been turning her
into a nerd and to my knowledge she
wants to get like maybe a tattoo of the
star one crazy thing is like people that
started in this generation like you know
the Xbox one and the ps4 generation
started gaming like that cool that's a
good experience but like there was
nothing like you know when it was
starting to become mainstream and people
were noticing gaming like playing games
then come on
you know silver back all the way like
ten years ago where I'm sitting there
I'm in the living room you know I'm at
my cousin's house we just got a play we
just got done playing and I just kicked
him with the lugia and I'm like where's
my PS this this man went in the bath and
was trying to trade my lugia to him
savage yes one era I got a job promoting
the school that I was in the high school
that I was in for at the mall like
little stand you know work working there
for like one of the winter breaks or
spring breaks or somewhere like that it
was about 1 month 1 to 1 to 2 month gig
just promoting the school so I could
just sit there read books and cuz I was
a huge huge reader those years I've now
I just listen to them I don't have time
but I would just sit there and read them
and if people have questions about the
school then I would just so him but it
was easy money right I mean it was when
the ps2 was coming out so I all my money
like once I found out that like the
store in town was going to have some I
went down there and I would see if I
could get into like the pre-order list
and only able to do so and I put myself
my name down without even knowing
whether I was gonna even have the money
to buy so I'm trying to figure out how
to do this and I talked to the person
that hired me for that gig and I asked
pretty much like three weeks in and
this was like a little bit less than
half of the amount of time that I was
supposed to be working I'm like can you
just pay me in full I knew they weren't
gonna get it so I kind of gave them this
the the salesman's pitch of what I was
buying without like lying which I'm like
it's an all-in-one entertainment system
you know you like it plays that they're
like now you again Estelle's men since
that Super Nintendo you've been selling
people on what you're getting next when
you told them of is the value for your
dollar to this next guy your employer
let me get the advance on my current
check it's just this one window and
everything so it that sounded way better
than saying I want to buy a game console
like they were I knew they weren't gonna
get it so I did get the events I went
over and there I'm sitting with you know
I come out of the store which was like
this shady shady store by the way this
is like where you could go and pilots
thought I got up early they did get they
get him early at least I think they just
like me maybe knew somebody in the US or
something I would like get a shipment of
like 10 of them or something because you
you would rent you that was the play
brief oh and you could rent a couple
games or you could just buy all the
pirated game which everybody was doing
and that was the first console that I
actually like you know put all my money
into like and I'm on myself and I'm out
of there in like 15 at the time or
something and I'm looking at the big box
I'm super happy and then it hits me I'm
like I have no games I just put
everything into this I don't have any
more games I go oh
and I'm like okay I don't like the [ __ ]
I'm gonna do now so my mom looked at it
she like gave me money to go buy
like oh so just say it went from me
buying the games for the game for like
me buying my first system and then my
mom just like giving me a like a little
bit of a push up like yeah this is so go
buy game so I went and I looked at the
games were available I didn't know what
these games were most of them more and
stuff so I ever get that oa2 so I was
like well that's a fighting game okay I
had never heard of it before so I love
the unshaven that quite a bit because
that was the only game I had at the time
and yeah I just slowly started building
a collection that's also when I started
dating my now wife she was a trooper she
would like to sit there she was my
audience right so she was experience
these games with me even though she
didn't really care too much about them
getting ready to yes I started getting
her into it when I got milk your solid
two she thought that the character
designs were kind of sexy it was one of
those games I just started engrossing
you it started like actually making you
a little bit of a paranoid like this a
gamer just like them telling me
something going on in the world that was
that was another like great gaming era
for me because not only was i
experiencing all these like titles that
are now cemented into like you know as
like pillars of gaming that we like
refer back to but I was experiencing
them with like my significant other and
she was getting into the internal here
she didn't like pick up the controller
and play with me but she was like
appreciative of it awesome and she knew
that I really liked that she knew that I
wanted to do something related to that
stuff so she was very very supportive we
were playing in one of the games that we
got together was a fatal frame
Oh decide well I'm like oh this looks
interesting as I'm so like I remember
grabbing my stepdads stereo system from
the living room and coming up and trying
to figure out how to hook up because I
heard heard that sound was so important
in this game and everything so I wanted
to recreate that like darkness of
something that we had experienced in
Silent Hill with her and she had she
wasn't there for that so I wanted her to
experience that right we would play at
night and stuff I figure how to cook up
like these huge speakers with like the
entire system which I was not really
allowed to touch even to put CDs in
without asking for permission just took
it all and moved it from the living room
into my bedroom Wow and put it all up
and you know was playing and that's
actually still one of the games that my
wife remembers how what was that camera
King you you you you were very intuitive
which I did that recreate those
experiences they do it digs we do that
suppossed a lot of that and then
eventually I had a graduate I had a
graduate a high school and I've been
looking into how to make Kingston so I
just yeah which is what I was gonna ask
you so pretty much like that right there
that you know from the place they should
air on and that kind of set you up with
a transition to come lead you into that
passion so like as far as like the
obviously we know you feel level design
stuff like that but like from the
artistic standpoint like how did you
start let's talk about lauralouise the
artists like how did that start and then
evolve into the level design so I've
always drawn so when I was a little kid
I just like when I wasn't gaming in
stuff like that I was always drawing so
I was like draw Looney Tunes and
withdrawn tiny toons Olo that stuff
right I would just draw them I would
like get a picture of that or trying to
like replicate it and copy it like
that's what I thought you did as an
artist was just looking at it stuff and
copying it because that's what I saw in
actual fine art like these you know you
have model you painters so that's what I
thought art was and so the entire time
when I was a kid and teacher I would
just draw things that I
you know other people drew because I
thought that's what you did and I was
already very creative but when it came
down to it looking into making games
I couldn't get information in Mexico
this is like you know asking for I don't
know like water where they're like
people have never seen water in their
life nobody could give me information
and it was really hard and this is like
beginner of Internet era becoming
popular so right not everybody had
internet not everybody knew what I
needed and people thought oh right
because you're like I want to make games
and they would kind of laugh like a
kirby series what do you want to do in
life I'm like nod that's what I want to
do though it took a lot of effort and a
lot of research I found like a program
that eventually was like if you want to
do this you probably want to learn some
programming right I'm like okay so I got
to do that and because of that during
the last couple years of high school
high school in in Mexico at least
compared to here from what I've heard in
your last year you kind of choose like
your specialty cuz we're going in
excellence yes so there's kind of like a
yes well there's like the math
mathematic scientists physics kind of a
path there's the biology and medical
field and social studies sort of like
art studies and stuff like that right
even though I'm a maybe would have gone
into art stuff knowing that I would need
to be proficient and programming and
learning all these technical things I
went into the science side of it so
learning you know calculus and all the
advanced math stuff to go into
engineering so I look into engineering
schools to start a computer study
computer science and I remember one of
the interviews I had at one of those
schools my uncle was with my uncle who
got me into gaming he was a human with
me to all these schools in Mexico City
to try to like figure out where I was
going to study and they asked me is but
what do you want is what I want to do
and I'm like I want to make games and
you remember the recruiter laughing even
like whether you go for your Armel you
want to do and then come back when
you're ready to actually study for real
I was like did you get his name so you
can offer quest them on Facebook so you
can be like
I had at the time was I think was like
the Sony palm or something that was
really popular I remember Paul yes oh
she's pulling that out as she's writing
the notes about me and something I got
to keep a file on me right when she says
that I'm like you know we've never had
in my family you've never had a lot of
money in stuff like that we were always
like we're never like starving or
anything but we're always just doing
getting by yeah and so for me it was I'm
like I found that I felt that was so
smug of her to be doing that I pulled up
like a paper note and from my back my
back pocket and my little pen I was just
like wait he was old okay give me the
phone
like I was trying to replicate her
gestures with her palm with me on my
actual paper no oh you're so I was
making fun of her without even knowing
that was making fun of her kind of thing
I I didn't find it like nice that you
know I was actually being serious about
it take it you see look
so I mean I got the last laugh though it
was a different it was a different time
and stuff like that nowadays there's
like programs to study that stuff how to
make it so anyway um I I am enrolled in
a school where I finally I'm like okay
I'm gonna start Computer Engineering at
this school and stuff like that I passed
the test I will not accept it it's a
nice just think it was about a month
before I I was going to start they are
was gonna move down to Mexico City with
my grandparents and go to school and I
used to subscribe to this gaming
magazine which one which one give me I
don't know that it was no here what's
called a I think was called Atomics
high I don't know if it was particular
to just Mexico but it was the Mexico
version of the conversion this magazine
gotcha
so I would get it every month and in
Cancun it was always late everything
came to right it wasn't the main city it
was in a main city or anything like that
so you got a magazine there it would be
like two months behind yeah oh my god
every week transy they have the new one
so they finally get the old two month
old issue in Stan I buy it
and reading the editorial it's not like
a tiny tiny article where it said like
learn how to make art for games and I
was like wait why you can do art for
games
like I didn't know that was even a thing
I thought it was all technical program
he's right so I start reading into it
and I looked at it I told my mom about
I'm like well there's a school in
Phoenix apparently that you know they
teach our games we have family in
Phoenix though like my like live with
them and maybe they're a money it's a
foreign college it's in another country
that sounds expensive
right like you write all that stuff
sounds expensive right it's like well
let's look at it and see what it would
be and it turned out that it was about
the same amount that I was gonna be
paying to go to engineering school and I
choose to go there and so I remember my
mom saying like it's your it's your call
what do you want to do and like yeah
just don't waste the money I couldn't
read all of where I went I could not
fail a class if I felt like oh well
that's a lot of pressure
yeah like she would uh you know you
would be responsible for for for the
cost of that like that was really strict
that she was very very like strong with
me and that um a lot of that stuff so
everything I did I had to think about
very carefully what I was gonna do
because there was very little second
chances so really the pressure was on
lord Louis like you had yeah so we
looked at it and it was like because it
turned out to be very close to it I was
pretty much covered for most of I think
there was maybe three classes that I was
short on to be able to to pay for but
that qualified me to be able to get a
student visa and everything so we went
through with it and I moved up to to
Phoenix and started it was it's
basically a glorified Fine Arts degree
that they were gardening mom and so I
learned how to do 3d and stuff in there
but they didn't really teach us how how
to actually make art for games like that
it was just a marketing thing really it
was not looking back at it at the time
it felt great but looking back at it it
wasn't like the best the best experience
and so fortunately enough I made a lot
of really good friends
we were all very very driven to build
this thing and so we all kind of taught
each other so well everybody else was
like playing Smash Brothers in the lobby
and I we were in the we were in the labs
we were like just working on a lot of
stuff teaching each other nice and we
just grew from there you know we all
graduated and couple years later we'll
Here I am it's tremendous story because
like not only did you follow your
passion and you had so many obstacles to
go through just to get the information
about your passion so I got a salute you
on that especially the move
you don't say obviously you know you had
family moment you went into the unknown
you don't need to go for your passion
and then obviously that led you into
level design and all that good stuff so
let's bring you up to speed now as far
as what we know you for like the world
build or stated decay like how did that
opportunity with undead labs and also I
want to shout out your team I was we had
Lord foggy on in the realm of the Lords
you know saying house we all you guys
there are packs he's brand fits generals
I wanna shout them out as well as Jeff
strain so like how did that opportunity
start to now get that gig at undead labs
so I was over it a couple years ago I
was working at a pistol which they're
known for Scribblenauts yeah when our
game was coming out a hybrid for Xbox
Live Arcade game yeah skated the state
of the cake was coming out as well and
being part of like the summer arcade
lineup and stuff we would get it like a
little bit of uh sizzle reel from
Microsoft internally to look at all the
games that were coming out and right and
in that sizzle that we got I got to see
you say to the cave before it came out
wait what is that like I caught my eye
yeah and then find out that it was like
a local studio that was working on it
it's under pretty interesting he kept my
eye out on it because it was really I
just thought it was kind of really fresh
what they were doing he and a couple
months later you know I had a like leave
fit sell and went over to hidden paths
to work on some some VR stuff I mean the
time I had I know a friend of mine that
went to work for undead and I pinged in
him said hey
I'm really interested in working at that
studio will you let me know if there's
ever like an opportunity because you
would go on their page and even the
statement says like we're not always
looking most companies say hey we're
always looking for talented people kind
of thing right right so you kind of like
blind send your resume or portfolio
stuff like that and undead was one of
the few places that I saw were there
actual message was like we're not always
looking for people were very careful
about who we hire were very careful
about like thinking about the long-term
of why we're hiring mm-hmm so because of
that I didn't want to like just blind
send in my stuff and have it get lost
right my friend
just let me know when there's an opening
and stuff like that I'm really really
interested in doing it right I was a
year in a hidden path working on some VR
projects when he hits me and he says hey
we just got an opening are you
interested in applying that time I had
been applying to a couple other
different studios and the thing about me
is like I usually am always applying as
an environment artist because that is
where my like the most skillful said
that I have right from the art side but
I always end up doing all these other
things that are so much more beyond an
artist that are you know like more
designer oriented or more like UX focus
it's like your experience at the end so
I'm not like a typical environment
artist that comes in it just works on
his art trust me look good and then goes
home I'm always thinking about how you
play this stuff you know he's having
internet except like why there's this
quote that I'm gonna use from a friend
of mine like why little Timmy going to
spend 250 bucks on your game and not 50
bucks on like call of duty I'm always
thinking about that kind of stuff as I'm
making things write it like how do I
make it better how do I what is this
gonna give the player instead of what
these other games are gonna give him/her
give them incentive to stay right so
because of that it's the the role that
came up with undead I mean I had a
screening called Jeff and I shout - Jeff
yeah he explained to me what the role
was he's like you know you're gonna be
doing a lot of like moments moments
addressing storytelling and stuff you're
not going to get to do a lot of art
you're it's like 80 90 percent of your
time in editor and then the other time
maybe modeling for things that might
just complete the area if you really
feel like it needs it instead of like
the 90% of you know modeling and stuff
and then just piping it through and I'm
like you're describing exactly what I've
been looking for because I don't wanna
mean I don't want to make like that
artist side of me is I I just can't that
creative side but I just cannot not
think about the player experience and
how to like ball it like just get them
in Merce in the world absolutely so he
said this is something that sounds
interesting to you and I said yeah
absolutely so I got an hour test from
them sent it and you know just hoped
that that I would get it and yeah I got
an interview and obviously I think I did
okay so yeah I mean I'm there now so but
and they definitely asked when I wasn't
really likely so why do you want to work
here like I don't want to work here for
like three years now you guys never had
an opening to you guys first I would
like to say thank you so much because
you made our Boston experience the
highlight of pax that night with you
guys and meeting you guys I'm the way
you set it up but you know you come in
and you had the little secret password
you had to go to the back and the swag
that you gave out and the intimacy that
you had with us and we saw the
camaraderie with each and every one of
you guys so I could for you to say that
you guys are basically hand-picked to
fit into this team that you Ukraine with
you're skilled but he explained to you
that we needed this and you said yeah
this is this is exactly what I was
looking for it seems to be that they
built this giant pyramid with each one
of you guys as a block and it's
beautiful um because we pictured when it
was just I didn't I didn't I don't see
teams like that usually you know they're
like a football team you know they come
in with a mishmash of people you know
they played a role and usually at the
end of the season when they get the ring
they go off to another team but you
look like y'all are like you know solid
and very tight and the way that y'all
interact with each other having each
other's back and stuff like that we saw
it and you guys were the highlight of
our packs expand a little shot down
there laughs I really want to redouble
down looking the same because like I
said you definitely seem like you've
been around all the teams before but it
felt different it felt different you
guys had a camaraderie and again we
can't say enough to you know shout out
again Lord Richard folks who came on
show as well you know and just besides
just talking about your game we're like
talking about gaming you know yeah I
thought that was really dope and just to
see what you guys are creating and
obviously you know with the recent
success and I wanted to ask you to
transition into that with the recent
success obviously we know the
announcement we know you know obviously
you guys are now a part of Microsoft
Studios officially you know under like
exactly so like now that that's in that
that's era is there do you feel a sense
of like renewed energy at the studio now
what's the what's the temperature of the
studio right now yet it's been
interesting I think everybody's pretty
excited about you know what's to come
it's gonna it's giving us a lot of time
to think about what we want to do where
we want to really focus on so you can't
really get too much into into details
obviously but it right it's it's been
good it's been really good and it's also
been weird for me too because this is
the first time where I've shipped
something and I have to worry about like
what's coming next like do I have to
start looking at others videos like that
I've always had that kind of pattern in
my career and I think most developers
have yes oh so you got that stability
right now yeah it's kind of weird a
little bit of like just the PTSD almost
there like I'm like wait no that most I
mean there's very few lucky developers I
think that have had more hits than the
non hits or even released stuff in my
career a little bit the other way around
we're like I think 60 70 percent of the
stuff I worked on hasn't come out
and then the other 30 has come out and
not everything has been a successful
this is definitely one of the most
successful projects I've been involved
with
absolutely absolutely good attic using
systematic let's say I guess that would
be a you know pretty scary thought
process working with a day like and I
guess I'd be a different telling you
know going from a you know project a
project knowing that you know you're
going to be working on you know stay to
decay from for a while instead of like I
don't know what I'm going to be working
on this time next year he's a good man
and obviously we know you guys are on
the eve of the daybreak expansion so I
don't know how much you can tell there's
anything you can clip to the Lord's that
did you excited about I think a lot of
it has been revealed over on streams and
stuff like I know I in our designers he
showed a lot of the rewards and stuff
like that and I know Jeffrey's been
showcasing it like in two streams I
believe yes there's a lot of information
out there I'm not sure if you're looking
for something specific I mean it's you
know just your your involvement with the
project how excited are you
in reference to it oh I'm pretty excited
I think it's good it's a different game
mode in place fairly different from the
base game but it still it placed
separately from the base game but yet
feeds into it so okay for a lot of
people that are looking for I think a
little bit more of a quicker gameplay
session they're going to be able to go
in there enjoy and you know play that
mode and yet still have some progress
and feedback into their main game that's
in there for the long term so it's it's
pretty fun it's also pretty difficult
it's really hard to be hit I think like
very few of us in the studio have
actually been able to get even close to
finishing you a the permanently has but
it makes them take some strategizing and
some planning so we're very how people
are going to try to like beat it I do
that a question for you you finally so
this is a the finally I yes Lord addict
I put the lightsaber in the game
let me have it like this inside joke
with everyone and their lies like that's
cool and all but where's the like man
you need to put a Hulkbuster and light
saber he was like he's like you know
that sounds really nice at all but that
sounds really expensive he's like I was
like it's better to ask for permission
he's like but lawyers aren't usually I
the only forgiveness you're getting it a
loss because it's just got like humorous
to this it's a lie well what's your
gears weapon in there before we see
anything else we're very excited about
obviously today backpack it it
definitely sounds like very difficult
very cool horrid mode you get to play
for with your friends you know you get
to get new weapons and gear and bring
that into your communities so we're
definitely excited about that and before
obviously know about all that's going on
with up with that but I did want to see
something say something about your um
toys your history because I also looked
at your portfolio you saw some other
games that you worked on which very
surprised me and one of them was
actually DC Universe Online Oh probably
more credit than I deserve on that one
Sony Online at the time and we were
working on agents the agency okay the
agency and DC Universe were a same
Unreal 3 engine right there were
different versions different code base
for every single project but when there
was like a pivot in
agency there was like just too many
people to be working on it and instead
of getting uh you know rid of people and
stuff like that
the ICI universe needed the help so they
were in the her last year before
shipping and so they asked like who
wants to help on this project and
because it was like not a lot to do for
content creators in the agency during
that time it was a lot better to keep
like a little bit more of a focused
skeleton team on it with the pivots that
were happening yes and I jumped on that
and we helped them just create all a lot
of their site uh a lot of their side
mission levels and stuff that were you
know not core to the experience but they
were gonna like just provide a lot more
content for four players so I was in
charge of in this I was here in the
Seattle studio and I was in charge of
like a group of I think four or five
artists that we were just creating like
all these like the poison ivy legs like
begun or some of the metropolis
University stuff so a lot of the stuff
we were given the kid sets to make the
levels because obviously the game was
about a year out from shipping a lot of
their infrastructure and content was in
place so with like hey you think these
kids and just rearrange them here's the
level of the white box level just art
them up and the there's there's one I
think in my portfolio it shows the
poison ivy one and then like the yes and
it's exactly level it's just different
skins so it's the fact that you had
editing to do poison ivy and anything
you you the real MVP like really I
didn't sit there and like figure out
these systems with them worked like that
right it was like hey just help the team
get this over to the finish line so it
was a couple of us and I was
coordinating with the outsource managers
over on the austin studio at the time
and we were just you know how dailies
over the phone just checking up and
someone so ended up making like a good
amount of variety of stuff for them I
think the hive layers one of the ones
that I ended I don't think they had her
memory correctly they didn't really have
a kid set for it and they mostly had
like hero props
so taking a lot of their hero props in
the language of that and kind of making
a folk or expanding the kid set that
they had to make those levels so I
remember the the high one was one of the
bigger ones that I actually worked on
and yeah once uh once that was coming
out the door was like a couple months
like two months before his shift yeah I
moved over to do crystal nice that's
just of it somewhat someone likes up low
low cuz I could hit myself echoing they
go bottom yeah man like that is
tremendous man and I think the last
thing I want to ask you refugee was just
that what do you think like the biggest
misconceptions misconception that gamers
have about video game environments and
level design like you know just in
general like what do you think game is
have wrong about what you're doing
oh god that's a low key want to see
everything I don't understand why they
can't do XY and Z and this level that
are they're like what can you give us
some ideas like you know just to kind of
educate us you know what may not be as
easy to kind of manipulate or or just
things that you've experienced so I
think one of the biggest misconceptions
is that you can take any part of a game
and and slap it into another taking
something like you know say destiny and
saying why isn't there like a about
royale mode it's it's not
straightforward there's you know the the
core of the game is built usually to
sustain a thing whether it's you're not
gonna build the system's the same way
you would on a racing game versus a
fighting game right and fighting game
you don't need probably as hard of a
streaming technology no because you're
not moving from area to area whereas
like in a racing game you're you're
driving through an entire city a really
high speed like if the consoles are
limited right they have like a certain
amount of memory Simas of computers so
they're limited in the certain way so we
have this aspect that you need to work
with right within their space and it has
to be able to load that stuff has to be
able to remove it and a lot of the times
we make some sacrifices or we
you know make some decisions in order
for you to have a better experience so
for the thing to run smoothly or as
smooth as it can be we can't add more
content and at a more polished animation
to the character or something I mean
there's things that just can't happen so
like there are a lot of things like that
where it's like well why can't he just
like why can't they put in the battle
royal mode away from that one like that
that even me as a gamer I'm like I'll
just do this just do that but when you
start really thinking about it it's the
systems are a certain thing and they're
built to do it as well as it can so for
you to throw some other kind of design
feature in there just throws a wrench in
might make the core experience a lot
worse if you do do that so if it takes
time it takes planning and stuff so even
a small feature will will take a long
time I feel like I look at for temple
destiny and how long can people be
asking for a collection yes screen right
and we just now got it and I can only
imagine the amount of work and the
amount of forethought to that way yes
you do that into that even though it
looks very simple it looks like they
just added a section in the menu yeah I
don't even I don't even want to even
assume what kind of work went into that
so I think that's the biggest
misconception and then something very
small the mana cost that it has because
you're taking focus away from something
else that's if I ever start working on
you know on that part a lot of things
you know Shadow Lord boy I was listening
to yesterday you know something is that
as simple as adding a menu
you know they it's hard it's a how many
languages the game supports so they
gotta go do every independent language
men usually usually lead to sub menus so
you have to do the mid you than the sub
menu and they most most of the time they
have multiple sub mid you see you have
to do them too in like 10 different
languages oh you have to restructure the
UI to add these new menus mm-hmm we're
playing the era of you know games as a
service and that is a very very
different challenge because before you
would think of
the game as an end up many product like
you ship it maybe you updated once or
something but it's like it lives within
itself yes so you don't you have to
think about like if this game takes off
and we hope that it does like how do we
plan on sustaining it sustaining it
exactly how these systems going to be
flexible enough for us to make changes
that you know change maybe the core of
it or something or better the life are
in to help us introduce new features
into it so the it goes the design is
just so much more complicated thing
cannot further through going back to the
original question like the thing that I
think gamers like throw out a lot is
that they I see a lot of hate and I see
a lot of anger more games and it you
know it's a little bit sad because games
are their entertainment they're there
for us to enjoy and to take us out a
reality to experience something so for
people to get so upset about stuff in
general its kind of its kind of sad I
hope that they could just go and enjoy
it but because you're a really really
good gamer yeah necessarily mean that
the design ideas that you have are those
features that you think are going to
make sense in that game and because of
the reason is before right you got to
think about the systems the technology
and stuff like that so because I love
doesn't necessarily mean that I don't
assume that either or not I'm a strong
believer that every developer has that
control all delete button that will fix
every but yeah I think almost all
developers are always listening they're
always like trying to see how people are
experiencing their games and see whether
you know they can make it better or if
there's another one or what they just
think those
and bring it forward into whatever
they're working on next or if he it's
the same title or not like that we're
always learning from what we did what
even the stuff that we think was great
we start seeing players uh either play
them differently or the way we're not
expecting to and so we take that
interpreters it's like okay what players
usually tend to do this comedy for that
stuff now hey we're all learning we're
always listening and stuff and so we
might not engage all the time on
one-on-ones with people but but we're
always aware no listen man you just drop
some knowledge right there I'm so glad
you said that because again that is
definitely a big misconception a lot of
games to think it's just so easy for
them to fix it just because they either
you know skill at the game where they
have experience with a title or
franchise anything it's so easy it's
just like flipping a switch and why
can't you guys do that so I'm very glad
that you clarified that that was cool
so what we can do before we move on to
these topics real quick is uh pretty
much dig actually the question that we
asked all the guests in the room I mean
the top five games or franchises of all
time lordly weeks you're on the spot
oh you're making that one a hard-on
let's go
I can probably get them but not an order
any any order any order Metroid okay
almost everyone's guys zelda's like all
right now yeah so for me I feel like
that's the reason Zelda did so well in
breath of the wild came out like if you
look at how many guests have said Zelda
I think every guest we've ever had
almost it's like almost like an 80%
raishin yeah yeah think of that just you
know the the small amount of people
we've had on the show and they all say
Zelda the fact that you plays out of
four years the way we did and then you
play breadth of the wild I think that's
the reason absolutely yeah breath while
a lot for what it did when I meant this
when I was thinking about like winwaker
o
mine - Skyward Sword
he's like going against me but I use my
weave oh yeah so we got that we got to
get Delta we got met - prime series oh
my god I'm such a big gamer that I'm
having a really hard time nearing it
when I heard you say Silent Hill /
Resident Evil Waldo 80 of those in there
Silent Hill - Sahil - definitely up
there okay okay that one I need to play
these Silent Hill games man I know
what's funny is I was bored at work like
a year ago and I literally ruin every
Silent Hill by watching like a history
of all this like you know it all because
I like I always thought the universe by
Silent Hill was fascinating but I guess
a lie I was on some Punk mode but that
she scared me yes on ahead you gotta be
look at mannequins to say yes the
battlefield series nice definitely it's
one for me and man I'm I'm having a
really hard time everyone got you told
me but for sure yeah so that one is your
parfum a moment but I want to count in
but at the same time I don't because
it's like this one-off thing but it's a
thing that you just cemented a lot of
stuff for me so salut listen this is
your list this is your person that they
had the most effect when you as a gamer
definitely up there
[Applause]
because you know now let's tell them why
I've played PC games and some like that
but I'm not a huge PC gamer know a lot
of the experiences the destiny is
providing do a lot of console players
are experiencing for the very first Oh
it's not to say that they're like the
first ones to do it or they're the one
the best but they are they are
definitely doing it the best that has
ever been seen on consoles nice yo so I
played Wow when it came out I paid it
during Cataclysm Aaron stuff like that
quite a bit
you know Louie a lot of that stuff was
was really interesting to me and I was
enjoying destiny won quite a bit while I
was playing that and it wasn't until we
did the raid that figuring it out
figuring out the where they call the I'm
speaking out there named my glass with
Oracle's you know it was the world
the Oracles yes that just like there was
this click moment of light and because
you had never really experienced that
level of like you know fidelity of like
shooting and has all and yes every time
people like complain and say that they
don't like destiny and they I love that
I play 500 hours of Destiny's just not a
good game I always think to myself like
you clearly didn't play raids or
anything like that because whatever they
explained to me like they never have a
they never talked about the raid in a
positive way then everywhere in it are
like there is no y console that compares
to play a one on a raid my scientific
casual so we we try because we try to
like be inclusive to a lot of people's
and a lot of our members are they have
families they have small kids and
something that so not everybody can game
at the same rate so we try to be very
inclusive and when the rates come out we
try not to look at anything so we're
trying to figure it out so we might have
we thought we tried natural but you know
lurking david has a fraud week every
week I can jump into lfg and go with a
hardcore I can literally play that game
for like 20 hours a week and come on
here and get caught a fraud weekly by
this man that part that he say right
this factual I'm not going to deny it
because I get on that game at 5 a.m. and
I get off at 6:00 and some change to eat
maybe jump on a little bit some more and
night but we said the raid part and you
said the oracles and figuring that stuff
how there is and that moment or that
loop drop will use getting fake bringer
you know those those those moments
that's right now I know why that's the
major list those moments of how the raid
is constructed because you know people
think that like you said they could
build a games because they're so good at
them no I'm not that how can i my
humorous doesn't go that high - for me I
can design this I'm in awe of what you
guys do and how you put it together and
how the level of wonder I'm glad that
you guys as casuals do that level of
wonder and going into a raid and trying
to figure it out that's why we're trying
to get this day 1 raid up and going you
know get that 600 up and get in this
some people through the raid once it's
been out on once we haven't yeah I have
never done it I'm like well we'll push
you through it you want it you want that
or not they're like yeah yeah I'd rather
have it done but not done absolutely
anything like that get in a little one
of my biggest like things I remember
about the raid is when we were doing the
cable guard thing for the wrath of the
machines yeah did that lighting attack
where he just wiped everyone and I'll
never forget this like it was me lord
Cognito
and King David and I can't remember the
other three because they weren't in this
particular memory and we're sitting
there
students killed us three or four times
we don't understand what we do we're
trying to take her down we're like I
don't get it there's gotta be something
else and all I hear the next time we
died look are you
you know there's lighting doors on the
sides it's one of the most ultimate
co-op you know who either have
experienced destiny and then they walked
away until you do a raid for the first
time and like you said you the key point
Laurie said is console and and shout out
to the PC guys you know you guys been
doing it a while and all that for a long
time so while guys looking at us like
yeah we've been you know we've done that
kind of stuff already yeah exactly but
in the console space right there is
nothing that competes with that like the
six-man cooperative experience where
you're thrown into something where you
all have to figure it out you have to
work crap and sometimes split into
groups of three sometimes written groups
of two and that builds friendships like
when you survive a raid like that's your
brother you've been through something
together I have many people on my friend
list just as a result of Destiny's
arranged you know me and that I'm glad
you said cuz it doesn't get enough
credit besides the fantastic shooting we
already know the gunplay is almost
second to none you know besides the
artwork besides the fantastic music it
doesn't get enough credit for you know
that is the thing that keep coming back
over and over again and obviously we no
one is coming up very soon second level
to it right we're like not just figuring
it out like you figure it out and
there's that aha moment but then the
once you get good at it too long like
that just like friction is less they
like especially you I forget the name of
it like where you're lining up the door
to open it up and stuff yes teams of
three and you're cycling and you're just
like a well-oiled machine and it's gas
it's it's pure teamwork appeal cooperate
and when it when it's done seamless it's
just like me even when walking in them
they were they called fraud alert all or
Neil but he understands Lord King knows
how the gauntlet and Leviathan is
supposed to work so when everyone's
doing their job and especially that raid
which is very but
panic based right a lot of shooting
enemies and stuff
it's a mechanic everyone has to do their
job and the rate is such that if someone
messes up it will fold the rest of the
team the gauntlet in particular is I
love everything they've done I've been
caught late is like my least favorite I
agree I do because you can do your best
job but if someone else doesn't
experience is usually a runner when it
comes to that one so I'm always going in
as a runner and so I'm pretty good at it
but the thing reason I don't like it is
because it's the only part of a ray that
I've ever experienced in destiny where
your intuition it's actually backwards
or what you should be doing yes that
messing me up it was like to throw you
off or something I don't know what it
was but it's like the way that you think
you should be shooting at the lights and
stuff like that us look that's so long
yes a king a king I always tell them I
was like hey you shoot you to the barn I
shoot the cop that's the only thing
mentally to make sense to me yeah so
like just once we figured it out it was
like okay I get it now but it didn't it
didn't how about a Hummel Innes before
me part of the all the ways that haven't
had that because it felt like oh you
were just trying to trick me into doing
it wrong yeah yeah yeah it mentally
messes with you that's a great voice
mechanics and everything of it are great
which is the messaging with the lights
I think it's backwards tonight it feels
fun to throw you off on purpose like
clever about it I love that rave singles
the mess up guy tight like if you're
doing dogs and they see they see your
name at the bottom looking David has
been found what are you doing everybody
turns over cuz you have to have blind
faith that the guy next to you you can't
look over at his screen because you're
gonna mess up what you're doing you have
to just stay focus on your specific
position if you do it right you got a
hope that's that guy to the right of you
and I got to the left news doing their
job
fact they came out we had a raid team we
got to the dog and then the right team
just completely broke down and I
literally kept lfg in for two days and
finally got past the dogs and it's like
I learned how to do the dogs and a waste
like ice ended a long period of time I
would never do the rate if floored attic
wasn't the lead dog guy yeah he was not
the lead dog guy I was not doing the
rate was buddy is the reason he started
doing is because I was teaching other
people how to do the dogs in the class I
mean that's the type of relationship you
fool we gotta get movie a lot show to go
let's go
that's a Chad Trek tremendous fireman
putting that into I'm very happy loves
right very excited so last week's poll
results are in and the people have
spoken to the question before highly
anticipated Triple A game is released
how important are initial negative
impressions videos or articles to you
the winner at 67 percent in a dominant
4-way ILP poll is the null and I buy
whatever games I love regardless coming
in at 12% I've seen it to second place
right to the first time ever the the was
the first was there if there are
negative impressions I wait to buy group
and only if the spider-man puddles and
horses and red get are covered it at
last was yes negative impressions are
important it's all fair game group
thanks to all the lords who participated
in the poll loss are what do you think
about that man
like the cobwebs or you repeat the
question please
fluid density snoring slob is uh was
pretty but you know when a game trouble
a gamers release and negative
impressions come out the initial ones
like the spider-man puddle controversy
the are that supposedly boring horse
simulator controversy you know if I'm
psyched for a game I'm gonna purchase it
regardless if I'm on the fence about a
game then I do like to get general
impressions about it just to see if it's
worth me spending my money on but if I'm
psyched about something is it's hard for
me to be swayed from that thing from you
sovereign I got it no this question are
you are you so red dad's a day one for
you've ignored all enemies today I'm in
the trenches the enemies who are the
most worst on the round table
spider-man is on the streets please Lord
solve tell us what's going on spider-man
is out in these streets um and let me
preface this by saying I'm just I'm a
Batman guy I'm done my character you
know I always go in with some maybe some
predisposed spider-man experience by
saying and I'm a Batman guy's you know
that's saying something you know I like
Batman but you know what it is I've
never gravitated to bet it's a Spider
Man gameplay right no it's and in this
game
let me first say like when I think about
this game there's this
I think about certain words that like it
you know to me it's it's love it's
reverence and it's respect for the
source material and I think they hit all
three of those things with this game I
think spider-man fans Marvel fans
finally have their game that's caliber
of an Arkham game like finally feel it's
gotten there Arkham games I think it
depends oh it's better mechanically
mechanically moving around true and
traversal for me in this game is the
biggest thing
what are the bright things that I wasn't
feeling about the game is I could fall
like a 40-story building it straight on
the ground and take no damage whatsoever
yo that does I get that I get that but I
mean they wanna they wanna cry that you
have to balance stuff like that with a
superhero right um I think they want you
to feel empowered in a way that hey
whatever like they that was a decision
they may need not to do I can see if you
get knocked off a building or something
like that taking the damage but for you
doing it yourself like diving into like
the super yourself you know Batman with
his superpowers his wallet and his
wallet can't cushion him from dying
so the traversal in this game is the
best traversal in any open-world game
period I they really nailed it they
absolutely nailed the feeling of Spider
Man um and they made it intuitive in a
way that after like for me after 15-20
minutes I was flying around Manhattan
like nothing like just swinging right
into like a zipline thing where then you
give bounce use your momentum to bounce
it's absolutely amazing what they did
with the diverse on this game and that's
what makes it you like a spider-man game
no it's not immune to the open-world
tropes that allow the world games have
like ours oh oh the towers and stuff
like that yeah the repeated missions and
stuff like that but will
more fun than other games and you know I
love Assassin's Creed I love red dead
I love the oldies I love Grand Theft
Auto but what makes it fun is the
traversal it's spider-man so you do
you're doing it a lot more style than
you're doing any of these excuses lutely
then let's see mine was the fighting
game aspect of it when you actually got
into combat the super meter was building
up and I'm like what I tell you after
after after doing it for a while cuz I
haven't played that much story I've been
doing a lot of like the collector
bounced off first getting the city stuff
out of the way so I get it you're a
completionist yeah I ain't gonna go
around town looking for you don't play
games you eat games for eight years no
it doesn't make sense bookbags for
spider-man at work cuz there's so much
fun getting around like it's not like
Assassin's Creed you get to a place oh I
gotta go open up that Tower go up there
and dive off of it right it's not
illness like you bring up Assassin's
Creed like I've been playing quite a bit
of spider-man as well result essence
Creed as great as it is the traversal
has kind of lost a little bit from what
the original one was where you actually
puzzles on how to get somewhere
absolutely like the first two Assassin's
Creed Brotherhood I mean there were
puzzle elements to the traversal
especially when you went into like this
when you were able to go into indoor
environments and now that's something
gone and in spider-man like the thing
I've been finding ah you can't just
web-swing anywhere
there are you do have to be near some
structures and stuff like I have to be
able to do it more unless you could go
full speed straight into a building and
somehow start Drucker nevermind are you
getting mad at lack of realism in a
spider-man are you trying to bad-mouth
the game no no I'm just pointing out
some of the things out things funny
about it like I'm a huge fan of the
Batman games I love them I beat them
right it's better than those games but I
would argue that instead of thinking
damages what they do punish you with is
that you lose momentum so you can't
write yes that Flair that you have by
keeping up your momentum building up
speed you lose that right yes you don't
lose health but you lose Flair is what I
would say and I have to write I have to
kind of like build up my momentum again
start getting into the swing of it again
before I can start doing all those cool
moves and stuff like that you can just
do so I do think they have a little bit
of a punishment even though it's not as
directed to volunteer anything right
something by like diving onto the floor
you you lose that momentum and that
speed and those like great moves because
you can build up experience at least I
was building up experience from doing it
oh yeah they're they're cheap I'm a few
achievements they're trophies for being
able like to scale across the the city
without touching anything right and
seeing how on launch mistakes up in the
air arm and I and like Luis said like
jumping off of like structures and stuff
like that to keep them your forward
momentum going oh it's an exhilarating
experience that no other game does
period so in terms of the combat like
King was saying initially it I like the
fact that they give you so many tools to
play with and like a lot of these games
what happens is that you tend to start
gravitating to the ones that you like
the most right but so it couldn't be
overwhelming all the things you can do
and you're not gonna remember all the
moves that you can do according to the
situation that you're in it's just a lot
of stuff so you will start gravitating
to the stuff that you like most but I
like the fact that they give you so many
options to
the experience to how you want to like
when you unlock everything you can
create the spider-man that you want and
you play the way you want I do have a
question since you're a little bit
further than me is there like a true
stealth mechanic to this game anyway
there is stealth arm it doesn't I mean
you don't necessarily need it there I
I'm assuming there are some story
elements that they want you to be
stealthy especially I know I've heard
that like when you play as other people
other than spider-man there are stealth
elements that are not super great but a
Spider Man I've done it it's cool but
ultimately I haven't been to a place
where it requires stealth completely and
it's like a failed state if you don't
finish it stealthily like oftentimes I
could take out like sniper stealthily
and then just start fighting the other
guys so that's what I've seen so far so
this is linked to the black cat stuff
that comes out in the DLC game this man
speedruns today like this is Spider Man
what kind of I just that's what that is
regards to the suits right he's saying
that how is the black costume not in it
he was just like you know he's upset
about the artistic authenticity of
certain suits just not being available
you know what I think they're gonna do I
think they're waiting for that for a
little bit closer that game coming out
and then they're gonna put out a fallout
suit
I could be quiet so besides that like
like the combat stuff like I said like I
just like the fact that ultimately you
can craft this type of spider-man that
you want um every suit that you unlock
comes with a specific power but it's not
locked to that suit if you can play with
which whatever suit you like best and
then attach whatever power you like best
to that No so then again like so you can
use the iron spider legs on you know
like whatever regular other spider-man
suit that you want yeah it's cool you
can mix and match and do whatever you
want and make making your own spider-man
now in terms of the look in terms a
story let me speak about that quickly
what I've seen so far cuz I've been
doing a lot of this cleaning up the map
stuff so I haven't done a lot of story
what I've been collecting book bags so
when it comes to that story the story
but when I seem so far as well acted um
it seems like it's gonna take some dark
turns which is good um I didn't want it
to feel to like to sort of like fluffy
and not you know happy-go-lucky or all
the world sort of feels that way a
little bit
um so I'm excited to see where the story
goes I'm sure of the game not a
violation in the chat just now Lord
Eggman says he would say that we have to
throw a flag on the field I just got a
quick question for Lord King David we
know how he is you know we've we've went
into this multiple times of comics do
you think acre man has the the right to
judge this game off the comics he feels
it feels more like the movies than the
comics at the game
I think it's walking
line it's walking on line between both
its revs referential to both it has and
it shows respect to both and it's kind
of doing its own thing let me just clear
this up real quick is a thing called the
spidey verse all right and I want longer
but Nagar anchorman I want you to
understand there's a thing called the
spidey verse and in the spidey verse all
spider-man things are possible this is a
chapter in a spidey verse all right so
that wipes away any crap that you want
to talk about about this being there and
that being there it doesn't necessarily
has to be canon for this part or that
part in this spider-man world this is a
separate world in the Spidey verse
that's why the suit looks the way the
suit does it is not the traditional suit
even though they have the traditional
suit in there this is a Spidey verse
game this is their take on spider-man
like people are getting introduced to
spider-man with this game too because of
the new spider-man movie that came out
neither longer like the Tobey Maguire
was or like the comics before that the
the cartoon is up there I think there's
a big audience that he's just now
learning about these vitamin Lord de la
will he's saying that that's that sound
like a lazy writing cop-out that may be
for you but that's a way around just
being very strict and being I was very
one-sided with something they're giving
you their take on spider-man they're
giving you their take on the world so
everything is not gonna be 100% as the
books say you know understood that why
would you want the same content that you
get in a different medium regurgitated
in this medium but Wow so they can
complain that it never stole their
complaint away they're completely stolen
angry late
because you wanted to yell out so away
with you it's in the bushes but let me
go finish up Salaam there we get amazing
like spider-man game like I'm so happy
about that and that's exactly what it is
it is an amazing spider-man game that
makes you feel like spider-man in any
superhero game has to make you feel like
the hero that is emulating and it does
that to a tee um real quick in terms of
the look of the game I gotta beat the
game is absolutely gorgeous I think the
use of HDR and this game is fantastic
there's no real day/night cycle but
their date there's their particular
scenes that leave you in daytime or
nighttime both of them look equally
spectacular um
the only thing rain effects aren't that
great in this game so I would have to
say in terms of look I still give
especially I still give the Arkham games
a little push it in in terms of graphics
and overall look of the game I'm
especially Arkham Knight um but do you
think of New York ah do you think the
reason that the rain looks so good in
Batman is because it was night I they
really went out of their way to really
make that rain like that the ominous
feeling of Gotham hello you see the draw
distance in that game apartment compared
to a project complex bouncing I know
full well there's a balancing act and
when it comes to again throw a distance
and the scale of New York City nothing's
done it better I just have a quick
question for Laura Lewis when it comes
to like you know speaking of that is the
easier to design to do your job and like
a day cycle or a night cycle like not
both for them just like one or the other
because I've been told by a lot of
people it's a lot easier to to do stuff
like that and then the night cycle
because you don't have to worry about
like lighting effects and stuff well so
what part of it you're asking whether
like if it's easier to make it look good
or if it's easier to make a play with
good make it look good don't make it
look good it's a I think it might be
slightly easier at night because the
reflection stuff like that show up a lot
more then in the daytime for sure but
and you can do a lot of things lighting
does such a big job in this that you can
put a light source in the level and have
a lot of the crevices and some kind of
light up and give off shadow whereas if
you're in the daytime it's like a big
floodlight right that it's kind of
walking away a lot of the detail so
usually visually stuff tends to I at
least in my opinion tends to look a
little bit better or more attractive in
later in the day like a sunset and
nighttime right and I think like the
Arkham games look amazing because for
one they have a lot of detail in a very
very small area running out all the
custom lighting to go with is away on
plates lighting nighttime so it kind of
really accentuates what they want you to
see when you have a like a city like
spider-man right you have like the Sun
and I'm sure they have a lot of other
lighting techniques that help it but you
can't control the lighting as much as
you can in the arcade I would love to
see a visual comparison between like the
original Arkham game and spider-man
because we're talking about what appeal
it did it bring it and the hero game at
this point
so I think what the actual difference is
visually are because memory might might
be too kind to some of those things it's
still an amazing game but when it came
out when this one came out this hey
spider-man would not look the way it
does if it came out with Arkham I don't
think finish us off and then we'll get
an addict in real quick a question for
Luis so on how excited are you about now
that we're talking about lighting and
all this stuff how excited are you about
ray tracing and and and and how you
think you might start implementing if at
all into the stuff you're working on and
and looking at something like spider-man
and whatnot how how much better how much
how much uh you like and biggest stuff
that was shown a little yeah exactly
um you know I haven't looked too much
into it but I did see just some of the
clips and stuff I mean a lot of this
stuff is usually bleeding edge so you a
little bit of time for to kind of make
it into like Mass
Media like common I don't know and I
cried for sake probably using it but as
time goes on tech for games that's what
just gets better better it actually
allows us to make things that take a
long time to just like happen a lot
quicker and they look a lot better
because of it so we have more time left
to polish that instead of like having to
can craft it from scratch or so there's
to me is just gonna shortcut us into
being able to polish things more and
more so pretty excited but I don't know
when it'll actually you'll start seeing
it in game stuff and games that are you
know kind of linear you got like the
gears and stuff like that I think
they're gonna take way more advantage of
that technology and then open-world
games because you're just you're
leveraging like a cup of content in a
cup versus like in a tub analogy yes our
attic man obviously did the chat is not
happy with you so your impressions
excitement you know what I was actually
about this thing not to pawpaws this
stuff but since you guys are in your you
know your stuff over there in the
comment section because I don't like the
fact that I can be going 60 down the
road and hit a wall straight up and
nothing happens no kind of the animation
weird but you know I think we didn't go
into that I'm gonna go ahead and do
exactly what I was gonna do and not get
like to compare this to the Arkham the
two entirely different games I do enjoy
you know spider-man in the overall
filming more than Arkham like Arkham
more when it comes to stealth because
I'm more of a stealth person and
spider-man it's clear that they want you
to be more you know punching people than
anything else and clearly this was more
directed towards the general audience
them was he being fool coming for he
said add it get back to your speedruns
let the gamers enjoy to get yo taken Tom
you out there I feel like this this game
the bigger relevance than what people
are thinking it's an amazing game
I haven't even played more than
two hours of the game okay and I enjoyed
every bit of it I almost left destiny to
go play crap go play spider-man and when
I say almost like I hope I didn't do it
but I almost it had that effect to
almost pull you away from destiny and
what I want to come in
you know insomnia for a couple of things
one thing I want to come in them for
making a great spider-man game I feel
like this is something that the Arkham a
lot of people thought was a flood they
thought only one studio can do it I feel
like with spider-man we might start
seeing good comic book superhero games
in general because now it's clear that
it's it could sell right lighter man is
going to do numbers I still don't think
I'm a little bit more like give you
about seventy thirty I did give you 90
10 think with this you know you'll be
able to you know see more of these games
going forward like maybe we will get a
good Iron Man I'd like to see a black
panther game Charlie and I'll be living
and one thing I really want to point out
is the game that really started a comic
book games starting to evolve in general
which i felt like was wolf not
Wolfenstein Wolverine back on the ps3
and 360 I feel like that you know opened
up the doors ultimate destruction
and everyone's carving up potentially
perfect cosign and he's saying Arkham
redefined Batman in the gaming space
he said spider-man on ps4 is just set
out to make a good Spidey game based on
what already existed he said all the
elements can be found in prior game
right now so you mean to tell me that
self games
oh [ __ ] hater there's been stealth games
for the longest time we're gonna start
saying spoiler so don't do nothing new
because it's a stealth game beep did
stuff new because it did it ten years
ago
stop trying to demote a game because I I
think what you're saying is that the
Arkham games were the first of his kind
to incorporate Batman in that way there
was no Batman game like that before so
whereas spider-man 2 existed like 15
years ago we're gonna dismiss this one I
don't disagree with that assessment I
think this is much like Mario Odyssey
it's it's a polishing it's a polishing
of systems have been there before let's
get to the rest of these topics and it's
not afraid of facts the game is good we
have a it's about our guests so you can
go back in the bush condemn not content
on what occurred on them is that photo
mode is clearly helping them I think a
photo mode the photo mode itself has
probably sold them a couple hundred
thousand units by itself because oh you
know I go on Twitter I see that it looks
really
nice so you know I want to you know
condone them on that the games good
I haven't even played more than two
hours and I yeah I'm not even joking you
guys I was grinding like crazy yesterday
on destiny but almost at every point
that I was done with an event like I
could jump back on spider-man yes so you
know I want to give them to give my
hat's off to them now was it a 97 and
all that nonsense I was hearing no but I
feel like spider-man is that point that
you know we have another game that could
show these developers if you make a
superhero game right people will buy it
so I that's what I want to see I want to
see more well-put-together games than
this game no no because obviously I
probably have at least time next
thinking addict I mean like I said only
been about I don't have whatever but the
first thing I say is obviously
graphically wow it looks impressive I
felt one thing that was really cool was
DD transitions like the seamless
transition between gameplay and
cinematic that was really cool and then
they have some little details that are
really cool like when the voice actor is
talking like based on spider-man's
exertion it's like they redid the lines
like he's swinging and having a
conversation you can hear the breathing
the talk I'm saying like while he's
attorneys as opposed to when he's having
the same conversation if you're
stationary his voice is here so they got
nice little touches you know two anchors
point I do see what he's saying like
it's like it's probably one of those
games that's not doing anything that's
never been done before but it's also it
kind of has a little zeldo anyways like
it has all these different little
systems but it does them well you know
saying that that's what I felt I feel
like they're bad but it just does a lot
of systems well and graphically looks
great which is it was the last Batman
before the Arkham's yeah Batman Begins
that was horrible
I remember that King yeah was about
stove and it was like a puzzle or
isometric game it was a top-down game um
so there goes the self aspect of that
and that's where they basically grounded
it in that and the technology allowed
them to do and use the Unreal Engine and
the forces and the ways that they did no
that's the justice of energy anchor
you're getting let them in the doors
closed
we're going to keep going we have other
topics we have a guest that is a
fantastic guest wealth of knowledge and
we're not being dragged the roundtable
was not there today you do not get over
500 point Lord Lewis on your impressions
of spider-man I'm having a blast playing
it it's just like I said like it feels
like I'm spider-man when I'm playing it
and that's one of the things to do is so
you the illusion of the whatever the
fantasy is right I definitely feel the
controls felt slightly weird to me at
the beginning because I was kind of
expecting more but my Assassin's Creed
like just hold it and I'll be able to
like swing around and kind of it doing
the work for me yes and it's not all the
way there it forces you to try to do it
so once I'm playing on hard mode I'm
playing it like so that everybody's like
attacking you all the time you look like
that I don't know what the like normal
mode feels like but hard mode makes me
feel like I'm actually spider-man become
how many like keep an eye out for
everything on that like calendar meter
and the camera timing looking at my
environment to see if I can throw things
at them itself so like once I'm done
with a five like the way I move my
fingers with a controller feels like I'm
actually like the character so it's
selling me the fantasy of being
spider-man to me and super fun vibrant
game that's ultimately what I think it's
like giving me it's it's it's it's pure
joy where it's like Batman was you know
talking about Batman me it was more like
a this you I was more interested in the
story and but kinda like the grimness of
eight in darkness and stuff I can be
like rift with the Joker kind of thing
going on
this has like this like just
fun tone on it with like some
seriousness happening with the story and
where the characters are heading was
actually happening with a plot but but
at the core of it it's like it's still
fun and I think like the art reflects it
the way the the traversal the traversal
of the comet everything is reflecting
that core pillar of it's fun to be
spider-man it's not like he's not a
serious character he's not he's a young
character so it's just fun I really
enjoyed I think they knocked it out of
the park absolutely and one last thing I
want to say too is I also felt that comp
the combat was very fluid it was kind of
like rhythm yeah I got that aspect I
like when the spidey sense went off you
pressed a circle you dodged kind of
weird ain't gonna like it took me like
an hour to not get you used to the COS
in Batman anchorman says sort linear and
I'm gonna do whatever I want personal
right second off like in Batman when
when you're about to like you know do
that sense and what's over they had I'm
sure you're mentally looking for over
their head and I'm getting rocked
because I'm doing the web the dodge with
the web like you dodge just in time he
does this really cool movie in perfect
touch where was their faith or something
and that like feels so good yes and I
think to Louis's point I think that the
coolest part about the combat is just
that learning to see the tales like when
your spider sense tingling or getting
attacked from behind by either like like
like like a rocket launcher and then
looking at your environment to see what
you can do within the environment to
sort of counter that sort of stuff
that's where the fun is like there's a
lot of countering it's not the same way
that a Batman game counters but it's
about moving around the environment and
dodging this stuff and then getting back
into combat it's it's it's so
technically what you're saying is
they're doing stuff that hasn't been
done in a spider-man game before one
more thing that you know though in put
to rest this whole anchorman thing look
does this game do anything different
than you know spider-man too in a way
no it doesn't but I feel like
first off Sony taking over the range
only thing I just say that it does the
same thing as spider-man to his swing on
webs and then even then the swing and
all webs is different but you know when
it comes to you know that perspective
yes first of all how else do you make a
spider-man game anyway like that second
off this game was clearly you know made
by inspired by Sony because it's it's
really cinematic I could tell that in
the first you know forty to forty
minutes it just the way that they did
that you know how my how Sony it's not
even a bad thing likes to take your the
controller away from you momentarily a
lot throughout their games I think it
benefits spider-man more than its
benefited any of Sony's games because it
makes you feel like you're watching a
movie and you're spider-man at the same
is yeah just like I said laughing
laura-louise knocked it out the park
also just that sense of fun and they
exactly so let's move on if everyone's
got this spotty
yes now we got to talk about the main
event o'clock out right Debbie to
forsaken is our in these streets and
obviously is it launched this Tuesday
and it's pretty much been fairly
positive okay and um you know a lot of
people out there you know putting
picking up destiny again and playing
forsaken have a great time with the
campaign so now when it's our industry
it's been a couple days now the question
to the roundtable is it safe to say
destiny to is back so I want to resident
destiny fan here you've got the
outstanding warlock shirt on sizzling
after play yeah no I think I think it's
recouped all the little like hiccups
that I've had I've been playing it a lot
since launch yeah I didn't play the last
deal see as much a war mind because I
knew that we're gonna fix a lot of these
things I was also busy at the time so I
gots a lot of factors and then the
breadth of content that is in there
it's just like it's
that it's great to see that I can
actually like go about achieving things
in different ways like all kinds of
different activities so just it's
actually kind of like too much it's like
overwhelming so - as with all the things
you could do it yeah like I don't think
I've completed any of my weekly yet even
though I've been you know playing you
have to bake they definitely require you
to do a lot more but you can choose the
activity that you're going to engage
with so I'm really happy with it I think
the story was was great there's a couple
things that bug me about the story
because like I feel that they assume you
know a lot of this like deeper lore
that's not necessarily extremely into
the the grimoire and a lot of this stuff
so that's an issue that's I think always
buck me a little bit about about the
story side of a destiny but I'm enjoying
it a lot I jump in with my clan mates
and we're you know just going at it I
think in fact I definitely see it as me
logging in weekly to do stuff in it
instead of waiting for you know months
before I jump in and he said the death
of Kate equals death the budget they had
to kill off Kate because they couldn't
afford get it when a coma at it go ahead
first because he's he's actually like I
said he got the badge of the week so oh
no I do I do want to point out that um I
don't think I want to comment on that
statement real quick I don't think they
first off Activision can't afford that
dude it don't matter what he asked and I
say I think it was more about tying
conflict that they needed to get rid of
Kade right first off they could have
easily kept Kate on I didn't even notice
they called me try to tell me another
dude was voicing him in this expansion
suits a little north exactly he's
amazing the fact that they killed him
says a lot right that means that they're
okay would do more of a dark tone
storyline because when people start
killing people that's when you know that
anything is up for debate I want to
point out that they killed the most
charisma dude they had yes so that said
that was literally I want to say that
that Cade was kind of holding the story
back in a way you can you can say that
he was the comic relief that they always
fell back on whenever they were kind of
like weaker story situations going on
look at it from the standpoint of their
how they promote a destiny it was caved
he was the first commercial they showed
was they ever since the taken King he's
always had more screen time than anyone
else but III think is that's I got a
conspiracy theory then goes into that
but I want you to finish your thought
and I think the fact that they're
willing to kill the dude that they
always went to to sell everything shows
that they're serious that they're like
yo we got other people I know we haven't
showed them really good to you at all
and like at all at all but we do have
other good people in this world so what
we're gonna do because everyone only
knows Cade now because what he's done
over the past couple years we're just
gonna kill it that way you can't just
show
look at Kate all the dog we got our
Korra that clearly has emotions now I
don't know where I came from
mm-hm Savalas turned into a complete
pansy I don't know how that happened to
be 300 kicked off the tower that's what
they killed the the speaker in the yes
one yes begin no but like a speaker
killing it was nothing it was like it
wasn't like it was an impactful but it
didn't make me care and this one when I
like when it happens to Kate like the
the nerd in me I was like yes let's get
our gun let's go revenge him like right
absolutely you had that incentive to
have like a Korra I didn't really care
for her before like I you know because I
made a hunter on top of it so I'm a
little bit biased but like I made me
care about our Korra now and so holla
I'm like why is he like it's actually
making me not hate him but I'm like dude
like questions question is lawyer so how
you kai you're not gonna ride for your
Vanguard like yeah and you know she just
made me want to say yes let's let's
let's do it let's go avenge him that's
what I think that you know they're gonna
go I think that in the story they
want you to think that safale head is
incapable of doing what he's doing I
think they want you to think he's
incompetent because I do feel like
they're gonna bring a character that you
know I personally think that their goal
they're setting up for Osiris to take
over the tower hey I'm up out in there
why everyone to think that Civ Allah is
incompetent because they want some kind
even our chorus said we don't see eye to
eye on anything anymore so I I think
that they're kind of you know civil
would all right now give tomorrow
conspiracy theory they prop Cade up no
let me get my tempo I have yeah they
propped him up there made you love them
the majors fall in love with his comic
relief the made you fall in love with
his egocentric
as his quips they made you fall in love
with this character because he was
central to it like he was in the
marketing his hearing was pushed day he
was pushed there and they knew once
those numbers started to dip that they
were going to blow his brains out
alright so the numbers dipped all right
people were away from destiny people
were complaining and they took the
casuals and they threw the casuals in
the bushes you are a casual this Dame
will overwhelm you it will crush you it
will test your resolve
now you may give up and say well I can't
make that light level because when I go
into the night fall and I see question
marks you can either say I'm not going
back in there because their question
marks or I'm going to level up so go in
there and kick their behinds because I
have to get this powerful gear so when
they stop catering to the casuals and
they kill Cade they'll let you know that
they was completely 100% serious
now this diss parts that you see when
you look at your Matt do you like the
art design is insane yeah you go from
section
to section and I know as an artist
Louise you can appreciate going into the
Dreaming city looking at a rock
formation that is it that that's that's
red or magma color and in the same rock
formation there's a crystallis that is
blue that is see-through that is
completely different and then you have
the smoke on the floor it's a different
direction it's a it's a it's the tone
and the music is different it's an
ominous it's it's it's haunting and it's
giving you that feeling when you're
doing these little missions and you're
going here you're going there's so much
stuff to do that everybody on my friends
list and we have an hour classless four
pages are per day literally of people
doing stuff wanting to be in the
eighteen wanting to be in the b-team
trying to get ready for this raid and
their jump in their actual question what
can I do for this and I'll tell them yo
shout out the cactus go look at cactus
video real quick shout out to howling
disco check out how in this video real
quick and and make sure that you
understand where we are and what we have
to do and also shout out to bicycle
check out buy stuff to make sure that
you see exactly what you're supposed to
do listen to the flash points when the
flash points come up so you know where
we're at and if you have you see any
lords ask them this has been the most
clan intensive DLC mm-hm and it
transformed everything that you
understand so be- good when I see
[Laughter]
sovereign on I know it's serious like I
know it's serious right he jumps in and
he's like you I'm here for the day
what it's the tone has changed so just
like we said is it is it is it taking
King is it back yes this back the
numbers will reflect it I know when the
MPD's come out the numbers will reflect
that it's coming back that's the only
reason why I was afraid for spite of
right after this DLC because like Lord
addict said he has fireman there you
know thinking about it is that when you
like with destiny is so it's a group
intensive that spider-man is something
you you can get to on your own and you
play at your leisure and you don't have
to worry about affecting anybody else
we're destiny like it yeah all in there
yeah I need to get something that's the
ideal time to do it there's no other way
there's no way around it you know what I
wanted what I wanted to really point out
that I'm really impressed by is up until
now the raid has kind of felt like just
something that's just thrown in and this
like the only other time that I could
say that it that that to my knowledge
that any connection to the raid because
on Oryx said unless you did the side
quests at the end like you didn't even
know why you was fighting the works at
the end like you thought you killed him
he's ascended somehow like yeah you know
they did in the wrath of the machine
where you can do some stuff and it would
actually tell you why you're going to
this but in the actual this one you
actually have lower going up to it like
right you actually you know have people
telling you why you need to go do this
so if those like you know you have to
you have like three points of it you
have the beginning to where you know
what's going on in the middle to where
you know you defeat odor on or whatever
is Nationals and then you know then you
have the raid that feels like it's
actually part of the expansion and I'm
just up in that tacked on it's I mean it
is definitely not me shout out three
bums me out it big discussion about this
on the UM on flashpoint about you know
is it safe to say it's bad and you know
from the beginning the way the the
characters are handled the way the
stories handle you can tell immediately
there's a difference I mean even from
the cinematics to transition you know
after what happens obviously week a
result the effect of it and then the
hunt for the Barons I thought the fights
were done exceptionally well you know I
mean as far as the DLC overall is just
seems like a love letter to the hardcore
kinda like to what king is saying where
it's like everything that we've wanted
from d1 not only
sit back is this not that it's back it's
been improved upon right so it's just so
many things you got the random roles you
have you know the weapon placement you
have the grind being back and then to
what Lord addict saying with The
Dreaming city like when you get to that
everything sequentially leads up to
something else so the grind is actually
it means something it's rewarding to get
farther and when you see it I mean that
thing looks like you're straight out of
like talking like this is let me tell
you that they the exotics are real in
this has anybody done the strike that
takes you back to the prison of it oh my
god the strike is done so well like it's
Fanta
- they actually make you go like you're
participating in prison the prison of
LSAT the best strike right that I've
played so far he's saying that the
phrases he'd said it destiny won this
match of the mind just the setups
leading up to it so again it's just like
all I'm gonna say is for those who are
on the fence - I still like look I'm not
there I don't trust him
yeah I said this you know with d2 I
would say wait for the rain let's see
how they finish that off because right
now everything leading up to that and
the launch of this game has been
fantastic
I'm pretty confident based on what I've
seen in the Dreaming city the blind
where all that stuff this look like it's
going it has the feeling like it's going
to be an epic great right it has the
feeling like this is something special
coming so I would say for those on the
fence you could still wait it's cool you
don't see what happens that way the raid
on the floor no on next on Friday see
how the community absorbs it see how
people feel about it but if you're if
you are or like thinking about it I'd
say do it I say do it
yeah the thing about this expansion that
I think is very feels very different
from thinking came to that it feels that
they've paved the way a little bit of
how they're going to be addressing the
game in the future yes so it's not like
picking King was the best of what
vanilla had to do fixing all the
problems it feels like they've changed
drastically what those systems do how
they interact with you
in order to be what they're going to be
doing next I'm maxing berries the next
year own destiny content coming out and
see how it actually plays through it
just feels so so good right now
absolutely I'm excited it doesn't feel
like thinking King it feels different
no a really good way absolutely and
again this those core things that we
always love the you know the big
shooting mechanics still second and none
the soundtrack the music is amazing
still like I said some of the most best
cooperative things in gaming the grind
is the event difficulties yet this game
makes it very clear you are not ready
for something you have no business being
immune like you had but that's what I
got to say anything back to destiny one
when you went in the wrong area yeah I
mean for me like I don't I don't mind
grind would I mind is repetition
grind doesn't bother me like dude I see
the way I play games grind doesn't
bother me it's the repetition in doing
the same actual activities to grind it
gotcha
I think like what Luis said like I like
back with him taking this mm-hmm
they've taken this and it laid the
groundwork for what's to come both in
terms of story in terms of like under
the hood mechanics mom some of the stuff
you guys are talking about like with the
with the conspiracy theories I I would
love them to because for me what they
did with this is that they Game of
Thrones you right they made you love
something and they took it away at
Norwood we're not giving it back to you
you know I mean you know and that works
and that works to motivate people right
so good to come back to the game and to
feel like they're getting revenge for
Kade and I think it would be great if
the next step beyond that like we were
talking about like Cevallos falling off
like people losing confidence in serve
allah what if there is the next big
thing is a civil war amongst the
guardians that would be to me
so like the tone of the game one skate
is going I mean that music it's very
like you know what I'm like the fact is
they're like they still have to replace
a hunter Vanguard then write a new
character with the drift like this still
now I don't like how they did the drift
I don't like how they just throw him in
there you didn't do the quest I told you
to you have to get the ace of spades
I get that but like that's going to
answer your question as I'm trying to
tell you if you do the ace of spades
quest
it's basically Cades will he's going to
talk about you have to find these dashes
you wouldn't he's gonna talk about every
single remaining character left in the
universe right but it's done from a joke
perspective as if when you find his -
you know oh so if you found this that
means you killed me so here's a letter
to you not only done with humor it's the
greatest story from Cain period and he's
going to get to the drafter spoiler and
you're gonna find out and is also some
foreshadowing there trust me when I say
that quest so do you guys you guys think
you need another sort of comedic
character to sort of cause like the game
is gonna be like this solemn tone from
now on I don't want a replacement for
him I don't want to replace me I want a
character that stands alone now I want
them to be strong now because right now
they look weak and um the stuff that's
happening because when Cade was going
out when he was going down when he shot
the thing and he wrote it like like you
know what pardon me the most
what is like that feeling I had when Kay
brought out his ghost and they shot it
and then he was just like I'm coming
home a son like damn I feel that my
daughter cry it made my daughter cry is
the moment he said that he knew he was
dead like he said she lost to her
favorite characters in one
spider-man and infinity war she
literally she boiled out of control like
juju I mean they definitely they did hit
it he went out like a G like like if you
wanna see some would go out in a blaze
of glory like it don't get no better
than like they did they went out this
way he's black yeah his way like he was
he was tearing them up and if you did
see the story watch the story if you
didn't play it you know get to play in
it is is it is how you kill off a
beloved character while giving them
props at the same time and again for
those who want clarity after that please
do the ace of spades quest it is
fantastic no one rather than yeah please
get that very important and it's the
cherry on the sundae to the whole Kaede
soccer the storyline one thing I didn't
want to like you know regardless what
they made soval into you know like I
don't even think necessarily like you
know he's a pansy or anything like they
made him into that character that's like
I've been through so much I don't want
to go through any more it's like he's
completely withdrawing on everything
he's old Batman he wants to just sit in
his little ivory tower and not like you
know engage in anything he just wants to
defend he is a defending side so you
know they kind of made him into that you
know I into that veteran with PTSD you
know he's actually foreshadowing he's
doing a lot of foreshadowing as to why
he feels that way but there's going to
be repercussions so to speak yeah and
then you know you got I chord that they
build on to or you know they she's never
showed emotion up to this point like you
know she even said it she's like you
know Cade was like the only person left
that you know I even engage in any kind
of talking to like who's the only person
I've talked to he's like means avala
don't release the idol on anything and
like she even like me and Laura Cognito
we actually failsafe actually
said stuff is really cool I like how I
don't want someone to replace okay I
want them to build on the existing
characters they have now absolutely the
story finally got right right guys I
mean can we all agree that this just all
the time they talked about story there's
gonna be so much and he lied and he lied
and this time they were actually the
issues they had with the stories it
wasn't that there wasn't there was they
didn't tell it in a good way in a way
that made you care like yeah I think
they got a little bit better on on the
the vanilla destiny to story like you
know gold was a such a great character
he went out in such a horrible way yeah
he should have been a raid boss I don't
care what anyone says
I would agree yeah I love like this
should never have existed you should
have done something with Osiris in that
raid you should have helped rescue tand
do his race well a lot Ethan should
never have existed
gotcha yeah man I mean that's what I got
everyone that I had anything else when a
forsaken I think I will save my topic
for next week all right so what's a
persistent or not okay cool and then
I'll just finish off this this is super
quick you know grandpa Nintendo back in
the news again yes it is I've been found
out that uh multiple switch games on the
Pokemon splatoon and Dark Souls will not
support cloud safe as we know that uh
Nintendo's online service is going live
soon this month I believe and this
information was find out on the website
and apparently there was some fine print
with those games saying that um they
will not support it so the Nintendo that
got ahead of the statement they got
ahead of it they praised he put out a
statement and he said that the vast
majority of Nintendo switch games will
support save data cloud backup they said
however in certain games this feature
would make it possible for a players to
regain items that they had traded to
other players so to ensure
play save data cloud backup will not be
enabled for those games so they
basically that's their reason they're
saying for for fair play that you know
certain games are not gonna have it
whereas you look at the xbox you look at
the PlayStation they have no problem
doing cloud saves on all the games every
game and every time breathe they so do
yes I want to hear what Luis says that's
about we don't bring this to I guess
what is your you know a impression of
this news that is just come out and
there's reference to Nintendo switch in
the clouds ladies and uh you know just
technically you know what's your mindset
behind this like what did you think you
heard
so I hadn't heard of it until like
yesterday I think or something so I
think Nintendo's Nintendo I think they
do things their way and you know a lot
of us expecting them to do things
differently it's just like not a thing
it more so I'm sure they have their
reasons for it I don't know when I play
on intend oh now I know that there are
just like restrictions and things in
place that in consoles that are okay but
I don't I don't know how like X or
anything like that it's it's uh so my
thing is like from a technical
perspective level we talked about
earlier how sometimes gamers have
can I finish what I want to know is like
we were saying before house on time
gamers they have expectations that are
unfair and you as a developer so look
looking at their reasoning for it this
doesn't make any sense to you I don't
even know technology like I don't know
[Music]
on the show right now like he made
everything negative sound so positive
because he was one of the first that I
seen to actually break it and kinda
exposed intend to as far as to why is
this happening because it doesn't make
sense that like a certain amount of
title including they're all Pokemon it's
a big deal like you know splatoon is a
big deal like they don't have cloud
saves and this is a feature we're gonna
be paying for you know with the question
you know also back to Louise again is
like besides the fact it doesn't have
that they don't even have a local say
you know I'm saying backup option you
know again if the if it was what we
paying for this service that's supposed
to protect this data but if the local
option doesn't exist for these games
then what length know do you not see
this as something that's problematic so
you can't that's what I was saying
before like I just heard about this I'm
not sure what the extent of it is I
don't know like you could you can't save
locally is that what you're saying
that's the thing so if like put it if
you're if your switch is stolen you know
if your data is corrupted on a local
level there's nothing you can do but it
could prior to the cloud savings you
talking about like put on a USB or
something like that right there's no
option to backup
you will dry for another disc or
something like that that's pretty much
what it is right now so people were very
hopeful for the cloud service so they're
like okay now you have an online backup
we could be good but now that isn't dead
cells is also on this five 419 NBA 2k 19
now NBA 2k 19 I'll give a pass because I
played that on switch and that it's all
backed up on 2k servers so that's that's
the thing that the developer got to do
it is that they say because you know we
want to promote ensure fair play so in
essence they're disabling the future
they have they're going to above and
beyond for like that but you can get
programs easily on Pokemon and clone
stuff on Pokemon for the for the 3ds
like I get that logic and you know they
can't they can't stop all that but I
feel like if they didn't take the
precautions to stop all of that right
why are they taking precautions maybe
it's because it's the console thing but
you know they're clearly supporting the
DSi in general so I don't know if it's
that either chocolate as he put out an
article that apparently there supposed
to be a $5 subscription service that
does say that that they are soon to be
often for the Pokemon series so let's go
you know they want you to do everything
through the Pokemon bank right on that
nintendo scrooge mcduck in your wallet
okay this is the thing that we don't
always acknowledge Nintendo has ever
ever been consumer friendly ever
the man that be put on in defense of
them is wrong if I distance the distance
is like yeah he's a killer but
[Laughter]
officially throw the switch in the bush
that's like I said what do you expect
for 20 you get what you pay for and in
this instance you're paying $20 for one
year you're not getting much forget
about so don't expect it but some do you
die are you that confused by those games
being excluded because of fair play I
treat no that's a stupid that's a lie
that's a straight-up lie that's a
student good that's all it is
but so no way to switch like that stuff
not even there like I don't even know
every announcement is tempered with
trepidation you know they're released in
the game but does the game come without
sound well like I said everyone's
confused we'll see what happens if they
get in front of it you know because it's
a little bit defi strange and references
cloud service and we'll see hopefully if
they make another announcement but
that's what I got on that anybody else
we can close this thing out all right so
with the initial last poll the week with
the initial momentum of the spider-man
spider-man ps4 launch
do you anticipate spider-man surpassing
God of War in first month sales numbers
the choices are a yes Marvel and Spidey
I'm filling this up extra one is gonna
have something to do with this bed a yes
marvelous body momentum is too huge to
stop be no God of War is a
once-in-a-generation master P or C I
don't care all my money is going to NBA
2k VC Lord Louise an absolute pleasure
to have him in the realm of the Lord
what are the secret projects you got
going on okay wait I hear Oh a joke and
I said what other secret projects you
got going over there Lord and I did
laugh with absolute pleasure to have you
man where can I find people find you
thank you oh they can follow me on
Twitter Louise underscore o1 and
Instagram to Louise so they can just
follow me there he's absolutely read
absolute pleasure man the stories the
knowledge he was droppin
you took his back man Mexico can't cool
all those gaming stories same things we
were doing here in the States Bronx so
you are definitely a lord that we
respect that has been key to culture man
and just see your journey it's truly
inspiring to see what you've come for a
bit absolutely thank you no problem
problem Lord addict what you got going
on man what's going on you guys I
appreciate everyone for coming out I
definitely appreciate uh you know
lauralouise for coming on I always like
to have you know Deb's on the show give
you your perspective especially you know
we can see here and talk all day long we
could say what kind of information we
need to apply and I'm sure a lot of
these devs that watch these shows or
like do they have no idea that none of
that is possible follow me on Twitter
Lord and IOP
definitely would appreciate a follow up
coming close to a thousand of
followers also you know I definitely
have the Destiny to review up on every
call that I will be streaming the raid
on the ILP channel on twitch nice on my
channel but I'm going to go ahead and do
their in relative native you can find me
at your front door here about absolute
pleasure Lord solve the dead no defense
force coming through I apologize for
subjecting you to our foolishness to
down you see what we do week in and week
out yeah you guys could definitely catch
me on ps4 taking selfies of spider-man
and put into this I'm too tall for that
one word BX sovereign one word though
you can catch me playing Tomb Raider
come Tuesday very excited about that and
also big shout out to the Sega Dreamcast
nice birthday today
beautiful underrated systems of all time
one of the greatest systems all time it
stayed around it was so underrated and
went under well there you go it's a
little Peter more putting that tweet out
was fantastic no doubt Lord King where
could I find people front which got
going on out no comment as part of it
yes okay well first I would like to say
thank you to laura-louise for coming
through when we met you my pax
we knew that you in genuine the whole
team was genuine and to have you on the
show is fantastic as soon as I got back
to New York
i pre-ordered the the big game even
though I knew was coming on the game
pass you young guys passion was so
immense and it left an impression on me
that I had to support 100% you know so
um and then you on the show and hearing
the story and oh man it's just like like
I said it gave me goosebumps because we
lived that too so we know that you share
the same love of this uh this this thing
this game thing that's pure gaming that
we have so we do appreciate you being
here today and it's definitely an honor
for you to be here um all right combat
talk anytime you see me like tweet out
combat talk that's like the abbreviated
I try to put it out on parts but to get
the full combat talk subscribe to iron
Lords podcast on YouTube and it's up
there in like part to the results will
be up today it's going on right after
this I'll usually do it in the morning
but we had the show so it's going up
right now on next week we have triple G
vs. Canelo to uh Saturday the part one
will go up and the results will go up
part two on YouTube all right I put it
out an Instagram I put it out in the
Facebook community page and also put it
out on Twitter as much as I can you can
interact with us there you can get at me
also please make sure that you follow
the Instagram go there you know join and
see exactly what we're doing this is a
lot of background stuff a lord sovereign
will be posting a lot of his pictures of
spider-man in the Instagram because he
has access as well to the Instagram you
know a bowl and it's not happy yeah yeah
let's get it up guys but shut up to the
clan you guys Rock I'm loving seeing
four pages full of people people jumping
in that's what it's about it's about
Enter
meeting new people stop clicking up with
the same people and doing the same
things meet new people learn new
strategies and we are all here we're all
community and that's that's why we're
clench Creech absolutely butter the best
Koreans testing things in gaming salute
ILP claim absolute again like I said one
more time you know salud to lauralouise
coming through you know dropping
knowledge telling us about level design
educating us you know on his journey and
it was just really good to see in an
optional pleasure and again salute on
the lab really like all the guys out
there with a foggy brandt Fitzgerald
Jeff Strang all the guys man and we got
a chance to come in contact with really
really good close-knit group of team and
we're just so excited to see what you
guys got going for the future as far as
us obviously subscribe hit that like
button subscribe to all of you youtube
channel and then the idea circle network
media multiverse with anchor man's crazy
self opium and obviously take podcast to
it don't let's be and all the other
channels out there also arm stream team
we had like some giveaways going on shot
the lost Naldo super-g lei l-boogie
trying to get a fix finish up with a
lord nintendo you should be coming soon
and you should be coming back Lorca box
will have the audio and the timestamps
all that good stuff up later on as well
also flashpoint 31 with my man it
bounces up to come all the action to
break down what's sake if you want to
dive deeper into that destiny life we
got that and combat talk like you said
king will have part two up there man we
really appreciate the support the
patreon all that stuff and thank you for
rockin with us at our new time if anyone
got anything else we got some football
to watch taking me well I think they get
to these games hope your fantasy lineup
the troop I don't know
[Music]